[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys tirion is going to betray dany
and because of that he will be executed
that's what we're going to talk about in
this video their relationship has been
on unsteady ground for quite a while now
and the last of the starks made it seem
like his devotion to the dragon queen is
critically declining
winning the battle of winterfell and
stopping the night king doesn't result
in the unity jon and dany hoped for
the stark's sisters are not any more
welcoming to the dragon queen in the
aftermath of the battle
despite any declaring arya heroine
legitimizing injury
and the truth of jon's parentage
continues to drive an impossible wedge
between the targaryen lovers
it's not long before dany is making
questionable decisions regarding the
invasion of king's landing
and tyrion and varys are ringing their
hands and wondering if jon would be a
better candidate to rule the seven
kingdoms than yet another temperamental
targaryen
once sansa tells tyrion about jon's real
parents and he tells the spider
verse becomes almost totally convinced
that jon is the preferable choice for
the realm
as tyrion begs him to reconsider but
despite tyrion's devotion to his queen
is starting to seem more and more likely
that he'll wind up betraying then in the
end
if only for the good of westeros versus
riley points out that dany doesn't
listen to anyone
which essentially makes her a tyrant
like the ones she's tried to fight her
whole life
material suggests the idea that jon and
danny could rule together
various reasons that despite jon's
popularity and good instincts
his devotion to dany and his duty would
make him unable to ever stand up to her
effectively
her power would remain unchecked and
it's getting hard for tyrion to ignore
the fact that he could be helping
another power man targaryen ascend the
armed round
presumably that's why he once again
started to drink a lot
game of thrones seems to heavily implied
that tyrion is about to betray then in
season 8.
while it seems like tyrion is
reconsidering his beliefs varys has
already betrayed dany and sided with jon
snow
and then he will likely execute him for
that in episode 5.
then he did warn him that if he ever
sees another person is more fit to rule
than
she is to tell her dead in her face and
not a plot or throw her behind her back
or otherwise she'd burn him alive and
what if varys do after hearing johnny's
a targaryen
he immediately started plotting behind
her back i do not believe tyrion is
going to tell daniel varys betrayal
i think john will in this chat from
episode 5 john arrives at general stone
and luke was there to greet him and have
a little chat bears
i think varys will say to john that he
knows he's a targaryen
and that he would make a far better
ruler than dany
jon would obviously reply to that with
denny's my queen what you're telling me
is the treason
so verse tells jon jon tells dany about
how she was right
he shouldn't have told anyone and now
varys is already plotting to put him on
the arm throne
then he will then burn varys alive i
believe here dany commands grey worm to
find and bring her various to execute
him for a treason
and this is a shot of tyrion concerned
and worried so it's tyrion upon seeing
various being burned alive going to make
a decision and eventually try to put jon
on the throne instead of dany
tyrion is not going to betray daniel or
jon snow but in my opinion tyrion has
already betrayed danny for cersei
tyrion and cersei made a deal behind
closed during the season 7 finale
i believe it's tyrion who sent her word
they were coming back to general stone
and so she sent euron to kill rhaegal
and imprisonment sandy
then kill her and make sure dany burns
down king's landing
but what if i tell you that's exactly
what tyrion wanted what if i tell you
tyrion cersei plan was to make danny
unleash firing blood on king's landing
but when he sees danny would never kill
the innocent he will burn down king's
landing himself and frame dany
if cersei did not want dany to attack
his landing and red keep
but rather wanted to end the war some
other way cersei would not have beheaded
me sandy
cersei wants they need to attack and
we'll find out why exactly in the
upcoming episode
and i think it's because tyrion told her
to do it i believe it was tyrion who
told sir that to invite the small folk
in sideways keep
and so danny would burn the small folk
while cersei escapes through the secret
tunnel
and then basically make denny look like
the made queen leading her to lose
allies
then he will fly above the capital and
in that moment they will blow up king's
landing and frame dany
i firmly believe here and betray danny
and it's all going to be revealed by
brain in the finale
it's not only a season 7 finale that
gave us some clues but it's entire
season a that has been foreshadowing and
giving us clues that tyrion is a traitor
in episode 1 sansa asks tyrion if he
really thinks cersei is going to help
them
tyrion watches for cersei and says
they're there to help
tyrion defend cersei which might add
some fuel to an already popular theory
about a secret deal the two siblings
might have made during closed door
meeting in the season 7 finale
especially census reply to that i
thought you were the cleverest man i've
ever met
implying to how can tyrion be so naive
the look brain gives to him might also
be a hint of tyrion's betrayal
and he's seen it tyrion is known for
reading people as good as books
so did he really think cersei was going
to help or was it all part of his plan
in episode 2 upon jaime reveals to dany
and the nor that cersei has no intention
of helping them against the night king
then he does not look happy because
tyrion messed up again
then he's mediterranean because cersei
betrayed him and he is in her mind
either a fool or a traitor for
persuading them all to believe his
sister
to which tyrion is quick to admit he's a
fool but is he really
are we supposed to believe sansa who
spent far less time with cersei was able
to tell cersei was not going to send
help north
but tyrion searched his brother and the
one cerse actually spoke about is he
believed her
i think tyrion and cersei made a deal in
the season 7 finale
and tyrion betrayed dany at the end of
the scene dennis says to him if you
can't help me or throw your sister and
bring me the arm throne
then i'll find a hand who can and
tyrion's response to that is i suspect
one of you will be wearing this
referring to the hand of the queen pin
before it's all over
many for shadows here even in episode 3
the battle of nfl brain gave syrian this
look
very interesting i think the final plot
twist of the series that will take place
in the season 8 finale is a huge reveal
of tyrion working for cersei ever since
the season 7 finale
i believe tyrion will then be on a trial
for all his crimes
we may josh being brian stark and he
will be executed for a treason
but also for burning his landing to the
ground trying to frame dany
this matches with leaked photos in which
we seek his laning set completely
destroyed and burned
down tyrion betrayed dany and he sided
with his family
but how is it possible one would ask
well actually it's all been happening
before our eyes
as most of us would claim tyrion has
done everything he could to aid in the
rise of danny targaryen
the queen he believes can bring
stability to westeros
her cause is the one he believes in he's
tried to keep her from making rash
violent decisions
so that she can be seen as a ruler the
real needs but has he truly been
fighting for the best of dany
has he really been making decisions that
would bring dany one step closer towards
the throne
just the opposite tyrion has been
fighting for house lannister throughout
the entire season seven
and we've all witnessed it tyrion's been
preventing health lancer from falling
during the entire past season
because of tyrion and his warplanes
denny has lost most of her allies
and her strength has drastically
decreased his plans also resulted with
the food and gold being unprotected
and basically left for cersei to take it
which she did
is it possible that he is being
outsmarted by cersei and jaime even
though he is said to be the smartest
lannister
is it a coincidence that all tyrion's
plans made more damage than good for
dany
i don't think so throughout this meeting
with cersei tyrion even confessed that
he is the one preventing hell's
lannister from falling
tyrion and cersei made a deal on their
meeting exactly when the camera cut away
and it's tyrion who told cersei to
promise jon and danny to help in the
wars to come
tyrion realized cersei is pregnant and
he's probably working to put the lancer
on the throne
ensuring his house's future how else
would you explain why cersei just
moments ago in this episode refused to
help them in the war against the dead
only to a bit later after her meeting
with tyrion comes back at the dragonpit
and promises dany to aid them
why would she change her mind all of a
sudden tyrion knows herself was not
going to go north as she started herself
to all of them a bit earlier
and so he told her to lie about it for
now tyrion told her to make a false
promise of supporting them with
troops and that they buy more time to
improve our armies
also how likely is it that tyrion loyal
to dany would not see through cersei's
lies
tyrion is said to read people and their
intentions as easily as he reads books
which has been proven right multiple
times throughout the series but
he fails to read through cersei he fails
to read research's intention
and he believes search tables send help
tyrion cut a deal with cersei
he knew she was not going to go north
and he told her to lie about it
even the scene in which cersei reveals
her true intention to jaime could be
seen as a proof that tyrion has already
betrayed dany
cersei says to jaime you were always the
dumbest lannister this is in reference
for him falling for her lie
but tyrion was also there and is also a
lannister if he fell for lie as well it
would be an odd phrase for her to use
i feel like her attitude and phrasing
implies that tyrion was in on the lie
this tyrion's betrayal might have even
been foretold in the prophecy in the
books
in george armor novels then he hears a
prophecy in the house of the undying
that leads her to believe she'll face
three key betrayals
the prophecy says three treasons fairly
no one's were blood then once for gold
and ones for love
but this exact prophecy never made it
into the show the betrayal certainly did
in season one miriam's door killed her
unborn son to save jogo's life
this is a treasure for blood since
miramas door betrayed her in revenge for
the attack on her village
and rachel only returns joko to a
vegetative state while causing her son
to die in her womb
jira betrayed dany for gold as he spied
on dany for king robert
hired by varys in exchange for gold the
only treason left is the one for love
and that would be tyrion marking the
biggest plot fest of the series
beside dany's love for tyrion that
fulfills that part of the prophecy
danny was also warned in a novel against
the dragons not to trust tyrion with
this prophecy
so comes the pale mayor and after her
the others
kraken and dark flame lion and griffin
the son's son and the mummer's dragon
trust none of them remember the undying
beware the perfumed sandy show
lion the house ladies are sigil is
widely accepted to be tyrion lannister
in conclusion there are so many clues
ahead supporting tyrion being a traitor
and i believe he is i firmly believe he
is working for the best of house
leinster and is helping cersei win this
war
i think he will go as far to burn the
entire king's landing to the ground with
wildfire
and will try to frame dany for it i
believe most of the characters including
jon snow and probably including all of
us will think dany has gone
all mad in episode 5 and burned down the
capital but then in episode 6 it will be
revealed to everyone including
us the audience that dany did not burn
it he was tyrion and cersei
bran will use his green sight and his
powers will finally be of some use
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace